scherz à sienne cher aux alsaciens il y
a près de huit semaines dans d'autres
départements commencé son combat contre
une pandémie aussi violente que soudaine
avec force et courage nous avons dû
faire face un véritable tsunami
seul le confinement et la stricte
application des gestes barrières nous
ont permis de ralentir l'épidémie est de
sauver des vies aussi nous devons
absolument continuer à respecter ces
gestes barrières il ne faut pas se
relâcher
nous avons la pression d'une accalmie
mais l'épidémie est toujours présente et
si la situation se stabilise la pression
reste encore très grande sur les
services de réanimation et sur les
personnels soignants dans les hôpitaux
comme dans les ehpad
ce contexte pourrait faire que la sortie
du confinement s'organisent différemment
dans notre département
quel que soit le scénario pour la
période qui arrive plus que jamais d'ici
le 11 mai et après le 11 même la
vigilance et la prudence devrait rester
de mise à l'éffigie lancé prudence mais
aussi en confiance
c'est ainsi que je proposerai aux
partenaires de mettre en place une
coordination à l'échelle du aurait de
l'alsace pour préparer la sortie
progressive du confinement associant
élus locaux représentants de l'état
acteurs économiques acteurs de la santé
de l'éducation le monde associatif afin
de coordonner les actions et les
décisions
chacun dans nos responsabilités nous
devrons préparer le retour des enfants
dans les établissements scolaires la
reprise des transports publics
la réouverture des commerces le retour
des salariés dans les entreprises
le redémarrage des chantiers dans le
bâtiment nous aurons aussi à mobiliser
des moyens à la hauteur des difficultés
rencontrées par différents secteurs plus
touchés comme le tourisme la
restauration est l'événement
elle enfin nous devrons encore et
toujours conforté les moyens matériels
et humains déployés dans les hôpitaux
shares est la sienne cher aux alsaciens
notre responsabilité individuelle et
collective cet ensemble que nous avons
respecté le confinement et cet ensemble
que nous réussirons la sortie
progressive de cette base